it's already been a year since we broke
it down from 40 to number one the top 20
quarterback countdown that's what we'll
do over the course of the next month as
we work from 40 all the way to number
one yet there it is last year it was
patrick holmes one russell wilson two
aaron rodgers three forget about jordan
love forget about the packers
front office not properly catering to
roger the disrespect that you
demonstrated by putting him at three is
what spurred him to become the mvp last
year
maybe that's what maybe i'll do it again
maybe that's what i need to do with the
guy maybe that's what it is it's all
about me and giving him the red hot
poker i know well i adjusted that of
course during the season after week 10
we did a little like readjustment and of
course made him uh number two at that
point but hey it's always a fun exercise
this time of the year i've been i worked
on it all last week ton of notes doing
all of it the list will not look like it
did last year it's going to be a
different list and there was definitely
some you know different moving parts
putting this year's list together you
know no no drew brees no philip rivers
young commodities that are unproven
coming through the draft you know
rookies who are going to be second year
guys it was it was uh i felt like a
little tougher this year than than maybe
i've had over the last three or four
years doing this
yeah i mean think about the turnover
that we see now with veteran
quarterbacks so how do you transfer how
you regard a guy with a team that he's
been with maybe for years and all of a
sudden is on a new team but veteran
quarterbacks move like never before
because teams are thinking
we want a franchise quarterback and the
only place to get one
uh unless and until aaron rodgers
russell wilson and or deshawn watson are
available in trade is the draft one
right no
you're exactly right it's uh hey it's
it's it's a prime position we got a lot
of good quarterbacks in football right
now there's no doubt there's some
superstar talented guys we got guys who
got
superstar talent that are kind of
growing into that finding their way
um so that's that's where it's
interesting and it was it was it was
tough you know big bends jimmy g's
carson wentz right his issues where do
you put those type of guys all of that
with the rookie quarterbacks uh i always
have the toughest time mike like through
10 through 20. that's such a tough close
little area nitpicking those guys as far
as really good quarterbacks got a lot of
superstar
you know potential and traits and those
type of things so
i'm just glad i'm done with it and
excited to talk about it now
and we're gonna get started on it but
you reminded me of something that i
try to emphasize whenever this comes up
five years ago there weren't nearly as
many
competent quarterbacks available to nfl
teams as there are today mark my words
this is the first step toward what will
become a discussion regarding expansion
of the league
because there's only so many games you
can play
in order to increase inventory one way
to increase inventory is to add teams
and they're going to want as much
inventory of games as possible as
gambling continues becomes legalized in
more and more states expansion
it's coming i don't know when but at one
point not that long ago i thought we're
never going to see it
i think we're going to see it and i
think the talk is going to begin within
five years and there'll be more teams
within 10. i i wouldn't be shocked by i
mean you know again look look at the
recent influx of quarterbacks we have
every year like you're talking about
here and that's what you're basically
saying that we can have 36 franchise
quarterbacks or something like that i
know not all 36 teams or whatever would
but you know enough of a percentage to
where we go this is still really good
football and we didn't miss anything
like that and it has increased i mean i
i think if we sat here like 10 years ago
and you and i were doing this show we'd
probably be going i don't know if
there's enough franchise quarterbacks in
football i don't think that's an issue
now you've heard me say before i think
there's plenty good quarterbacks now to
me there's not enough good offensive
coordinators going around now that's
that's what's really flipped around here
and with the sport being so popular and
it's flag foot i mean listen i'm at a
i'm at flag football yesterday phil i
mean uh mike my little boy phillip 10
years old there's a hundred games going
on flag football all age groups i mean
40 fields it's everywhere these kids are
throwing 30 balls a day everything
that's they love football our country
loves it it's only going to make our
best athletes want to keep playing
quarterbacks to fill those holes like
you're talking about if there's extra
teams so i think that's a very very real
thing um you know into the future and
certainly something to keep your eye on
you're right mike
at all other positions the supply has
outweighed demand for decades when you
think of all the college programs
quarterbacks where there's been the
deficiency that deficiency is gone more
nfl teams coming starting off the list
down eight spots from 32 last year at
number 40 the backup quarterback to
baker mayfield in cleveland the guy who
took a team to the brink
of the super bowl
years ago in minnesota case keenum
number 40 chris yeah case keenum listen
i mean one of the best backup
quarterbacks in football he really is i
i'd love to have case keenum as my
backup quarterback because you know as
you know too he's got you know
starting potential yeah the greatest
thing about case kingdom is he can do it
all there's no great weakness about his
game and you know what's even better
about it there in cleveland is he's a
poor man's version of the starting
quarterback i mean that's really what he
is he's just a lesser baker mayfield so
you know they don't have to change
anything with their offense or do
anything like that but case keenum come
on experience can move in the pocket has
the ability to extend plays
is a really consistent thrower of the
football really never loses control of
it does any of those type of things has
a little moxie and toughness about him
like no doubt case keenum i mean you you
got him he's the one of the best
insurance policies and all the football
when it comes to backup quarterbacks if
baker mayfield and i think a lot of him
and he's going to be coming up later
down the list closer to that top 10
maybe in the top 10 right i think a lot
of him but if he was to get hurt week 12
and case keenum had to come in i don't
know i'm a little bit like okay i know
that's going to hurt a little that
there's no baker mayfield but they can
still win games with case keenum and
maybe make a run in the playoffs and go
to a super bowl and that type of thing
so that's where i really love case
keenum got it all fits what they do
there and really like i said no maybe
weakness to his game maybe no great
glaring strength but no weakness and can
do it all
2017 sam bradford had a great week one
performance on a monday night against
the new orleans saints
showed up on the injury report with a
knee injury a couple of days later never
played again
case keenum came in lost at pittsburgh
but then took the vikings on a hell of a
run and his skill was escaping the
pocket yeah moving laterally resetting
and he keep doing it until he found
somebody wide open and the vikings
soured on him because they thought he
was bailing out too quickly and using
those skills now they have a guy who
stays in the pocket because he can't
bail out yeah that's right again
her cousin's lands somewhere higher than
40 on the list we'll get to him at some
point but keenum
fair assessment at 40 he is down eight
spots but i agree with you he can win
football games if and when the browns
need him to do so
now it gets interesting right out of the
gates after 40 we climbed to 39
obviously the bears rookie quarterback
not their veteran
but justin fields the guy they gave up
all that stuff to go get he's installed
at number 39. why so low for a guy who's
already other than tim tebow high on the
list of the jerseys that people have to
have well i'm sure i mean listen he's
he's a specimen and he's one of these
guys on the list that yeah he's got big
potential i mean if we do this
mid-season next year and he's starting
and playing i mean yeah he's got the
ability to be a big climber but i got
too many questions about you know justin
fields for me to like do what i did with
like joe burrow last year and put him in
the 20s even though he hadn't played a
game in the nfl i didn't i didn't care i
knew joe burrow was going to throw dimes
and make the right decisions and be
slippery in the pocket justin fields you
know he is going to bring the element of
running the football there's no doubt
about that his arm is big we know that
too you know and there are moments where
when he puts it all together it can look
as good as anybody in college football
and it can look special you know my
concerns we talked about it a lot
through the draft there's
inconsistencies big time inconsistencies
one that scares me to where yeah that's
why i did have them the six rated
quarterback you know coming out in this
draft i understand you know it's a big
time potential but there's a lot of
growing within the position throwing the
football you know in the pocket cleaning
up mechanics doing all of those type of
things that need to be improved so like
i love the top end thought of justin
fields it's just there's a bottom end
thought that's a little scary too and i
hope it doesn't get to there i'm not i
don't want to see bad i like this kid i
know the way he handles himself
everything about it but i just have
those concerns in the game to where i
can't make them higher than that right
now because i'm uncomfortable with some
of those things
last year you had tuatanga vailoa at
number 40 he had the question marks with
that hip injury he suffered between the
two right now which one do you view as
the
the higher end prospect at the nfl level
i think fields has more potential to be
a greater player i do
he's he's just got you know more to
offer as far as high-end talent his his
running is special like we talked about
he's a greek god built like cam newton
quick can make people miss can run with
sp you know
outrun you with speed we know all that
you know and then of course you know
like we've talked about he can make
throws where you go whoa wow like
there's no way tula could make that
throw or do that whoa holy cow you know
but it's some of the other things in
between where hey it's a 10 yard
crossing route two was on the money all
the time with that type of stuff where
you know again justin feels i can pull
up games and go
damn there's nobody around this guy and
he's like two for ten on this route like
that's what's scary about it so his
ultimate potential i do think is far
greater than tua but i do see a bigger
bust factor there too
the uh folks at points bet have put
together the odds the quarterback
expected to take the first snap week one
the bears will be at la to take on the
rams andy dalton minus 200 get about 200
to win 100 justin fields plus 165 bet
100 win 165 there's nick foles yeah poor
nick falls yeah the only super bowl mvp
on the depth chart plus 1200 i'll be
surprised if he's even on the roster
come september but uh i'm surprised it's
dalton and i know that the bears are
saying everything that they need to say
they haven't installed justin fields as
the starter and with them maybe the
dynamic is we're more concerned about
next year than this year because
the organization has implicitly given
ryan pace and matt nagy two years now
before they're they're truly on the hot
seat and they have some time to develop
justin fields you don't want to throw
him out there before he's ready no i
just think that everything you've given
up uh-huh to go get him he can't beat
out andy dalton maybe you shouldn't have
given up all that stuff to go get i i i
hear you i think that's going to be you
know hovering over the bears that little
theme and conversation you're talking
about there mike i think in their heart
of hearts they're probably hoping for
like a
a carson wentz type scenario in
philadelphia back in the day right
you've talked about it before where it's
like hey yeah sam bradford's the starter
he's the starter carson wentz has done
good every day in camp every good in
camp okay get it all right make him the
starter let's go wentz is a starter see
you later sam bradford not that they
would trade andy dalton maybe they would
i don't know they do have nick foles but
i would think if it's close or they show
that justin fields if justin fields
shows that he's not mentally overwhelmed
by learning a new offense or any of
those type of things and he understands
where to go with the ball and those type
of things you you you can
they could do it i mean they could play
with that that way his again his running
ability
is is to me a big time notch above a guy
like jalen hurts in philadelphia right
so again you can make some of the pass
game stuff you know easy and help him
kind of break in easily in that
department because of the threat of him
running the football and doing those
things and that might be the thing that
helps you know gives them time to grow
and work on some of the things we've
talked about
fields was the 11th overall pick in the
draft he comes in at 39 at 38
the guy who was the
third overall pick in the draft trey
lance north dakota state played one game
last year the 49ers decided they are all
in
at least in
you know
after they get rid of jimmy garoppolo
whenever that may be with trey lance why
so low you're going to have some 49ers
fans coming i know today for putting
their guys so low chris well i know but
i mean you know anybody that's listened
to me throughout the draft process yeah
i mean i i have concerns here too listen
i love the high-end talent again it's
just like justin fields the the
highlight shows are great when you watch
the highlight package you go damn this
is really special you know the one thing
he has over at justin fields is there is
more consistency in him throwing the
football you know but still there are
too many throws
in any game i look at to where i just go
i've never seen a top five quarterback
miss that throw three times in a row or
four times in the first half or you know
make a guy be this open over the middle
and he's gotta stop or fall to the
ground to catch a ball that if it's just
somewhat accurate he's gonna keep
running for another 20 or something
yards and he hasn't played a ton of
football so again it's just a little bit
of the unknown like fields and lance can
be those type of guys that can be big
risers but for me and my assessment my
studies and all those type of things
there's just too many areas of like
i'm not sure about that and oh i think
he might be good but
i'd like to see a little bit more and
that's the problem with like fields and
trey lance to me at least as far as the
nfl's concerned you know again it's i
don't think anybody thought that this
was going to be an easy adjustment for
those two i think that was a pretty
common conversation you know coming from
where they came from the offenses they
were in and everything like that so it
is again i like trey lance and
everything he does but there's some
polish and some more experience that's
needed and things that i need to see to
feel comfortable to move him in front of
some other guys who yeah he might have
better top hop and talent but they play
the position and can do other things at
a more consistent level than i believe
like a trey lance or fields can do at
this point
12th overall pick first round pick 2022
first round pick 2023 third round pick
invested
in
trade lands and they are playing with
fire here they continue to be all in
with jimmy garoppolo as their starter
they have soured on him because he can't
stay healthy well two years ago he
stayed healthy all the way to the super
bowl so they could end up having a huge
mess for a variety of reasons jimmy
garoppolo could get injured during off
season workouts mandatory mini camp
training camp pre-season and then you're
on the hook for 25 million and you have
to go with lance i just still don't
understand the mixed messages but the
folks at points bet
parched through it all to come to the
conclusion
that the first snap of the season most
likely to be taken by
garoppolo he's the favorite in the
betting odds and uh
minus i didn't hear you matt casey minus
what do we have it
minus 325 is the number for jimmy
garoppolo bet 325 to win a hundred
significant favorite to be the starter
and look i think they're hoping for
uh
carson wentz sam bradford situation
where there's an injury somewhere else
and somebody says we'll take jimmy
garoppolo we'll take his contract we'll
give you a first round pick i mean the
eagles got a one and a four for sam
bradford they were able to basically
stick up the vikings for a one and a
four because teddy bridgewater tore his
acl two weeks before the first game of
the season now that doesn't happen very
often
you know you got preseason games to
worry about but practice you know you
got the red jersey it was a fluke thing
so if that's the 49ers are hoping for
that that is not likely to occur if
anything it's more likely garoppolo is
going to get injured than someone with
another team yeah yeah i mean there's so
many different ways this story can go
right now they can be good and bad for
the 49ers i mean
yeah i mean you could have jimmy g play
does really good has a really good year
and maybe you trade him after the year
he's played a good year maybe you you
know maximize your value that way you
know there's the scenario you're talking
about again like we talked about with
justin fields and like i've already seen
it already happen so this is even less
of a far-fetched idea because i saw
shanahan with rg3 back in the day and
that offense wasn't as good as this
49ers offense as far as the talent and
the players on the roster like you talk
about like if it gets close again yeah
that's one where if it's close and i've
done all those assets to trade up to
number three to get this guy and i got a
good team and i'd be scared to death
that we're eight and two and jimmy
garoppolo is the starting quarterback
that's what i'd be scared of you know
that's it's just it's a mess can of
worms open all of those type of things
to where yeah like you're talking about
if it's close i mean i know shanahan can
deal you know come up with an offense
that's
ultra ultra creative now with a running
quarterback added to the mix and those
weapons around him so that's where it's
going to be interesting to see the
progress trey lance can make will
shanahan be comfortable with that it is
a team that's in the super bowl window
it's some really weird conversations
here when you talk about the 49ers out
loud sometimes and what what's going on
there right now
here's what i am going to be curious
about yeah next year if group plays all
year long lance going to be on your list
next year if we if he he's done nothing
in the nfl in his rookie year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports